relationship the whole purpose of the
United States of America is that you
assimilate into the culture of the
United States of America what what did
we always say what did we all learn in
third fourth grade we learned about the
Melting Pot of America which was very
different than what they had in Europe
and what very different really from
every country preamer which was the idea
that you come here you bring your
cultures your food your languages all
those things and those aren't the
primary thing anymore they fold into the
Melting Pot they melt into that that pot
that soup that creates something
delicious and wonderful and that's based
in Freedom and individual liberty and
all of those things but you don't forget
all of your traditions and everything
else you don't forget where you're from
you don't forget your family and all
that but you you have it fold into this
beautiful thing that is America the
problem now is that the progressives and
and the elitists who will tell us that
this place is evil and it's racist and
its founding was awful and everything
else they don't even like this place in
the first first place so they want now
to turn this country into the types of
countries that most of our ancestors had
to flee from who is an incredible
example of that well there's at least
one of them actually several but she's
the best uh several examples of that in
uh the United States Congress here is
Minnesota Hamas caucus member ilhan Omar
uh at this Somali conference from these
videos that have gone viral over these
last couple days in our
[Applause]
M
Minneapolis special
relationship
[Applause]
Minneapolis
is that woman is she a congresswoman
from Somalia or from Minnesota I'm a
little confused because by I'm a simple
man I might have misunderstood who she
is exactly she talks about the president
of Somalia uh who calls her girl and she
calls him Uncle uh we played some clips
from you uh yesterday about how she's
talking about how it's the Somalian job
in the United States to make America
work for Somalia I mean this is this is
absolutely insane what's going on with
this woman uh here's just a bit more
because she keeps referring to Somalia
as our nation our nation again she is a
sitting congresswoman I'm fairly certain
that America is our nation in 2016 it's
election
cycle and you guys have the ability to
make an impact on where our nation is
headed not only here in the United
States but even in our nation back home
our nation back home um she would love
to turn America into Somalia a country
that she fled and then became a super
powerful influential person in America
uh she fled the oppression that she had
in
Somalia